[Aplausos]
[Música]
había nacido muchos años atrás pero a
pesar del tiempo y la distancia siempre
mantuvo su esencia intacta necesitaba
del ímpetu de la juventud y la sabiduría
de la edad para convertirse en cada una
de sus transformaciones cuenta la
historia que en esta ocasión decidió
convertirse en un dragón un dragón con
ganas de cambiar el mundo y con su
aliento de neblina despertar a la gente
de corazón curioso y guiarla hasta la
verdadera magia de la vida pero como
cualquier noble propósito necesitaba de
valientes y apasionados guerreros para
que lucharan a su lado cruzó el mundo
entero en su búsqueda hasta que un día
llegó un pequeño y peculiar lugar lleno
de historias escondidas y ahí reconoció
a sus primeros elegidos y a pesar de que
aún eran muy pequeños él se encargó de
dejar piezas en su camino para que el
día en el que realmente estén listos sus
historias se crucen
tres sueños de papel nuestro dragón por
fin pueda nacer pero el cuento no se
acaba ahí
[Música]
las primeras pistas que yo encontré en
mi vida vinieron acompañadas de un
personaje muy especial el señor de
cabeza blanca desde el carlitos y para
mi hermano y para mí se convirtió en una
especie de padrino o un abuelo algo así
como un abuelito un lado abuelito yo lo
conocí cuando era muy pequeña y el
primer recuerdo que tengo de él es de
esto un juego él me saludó y después de
saludarme se acercó a una maleta sacó
este juego y me enseñó a jugarlo supongo
que gane porque me dio una caja de
colores que bueno después unas horas
perdí y me puse a llorar pero lo
importante es que a partir de ese
entonces de esa maleta no dejaron de
salir todos los juegos que yo me podía
imaginar y no solo juego siempre habían
historias siempre habían chistes o algo
que preguntar el carlitos una de las
historias que más apreciaba y una que le
escuché contar tantas veces que
prácticamente la sentí vivir es la
siguiente una mañana con rudd en sindh
ortega se paró a su clase y les dijo
muchachos el día de hoy posiblemente les
voy a enseñar una de las cosas más
qué puedo don rubén sin do se paró en la
pizarra y dibujo una línea recta estas
líneas chicos representan la línea de la
vida la dividió en seis pedazos y dijo
cada uno de estos pedazos representa un
tipo de conocimiento que el ser humano
tiene a lo largo de su vida primero está
el sensorial necesitamos que el mundo
entre a través de nuestros sentidos
quien no ha visto un pequeño llevarse
algo a la boca luego viene el empírico
jugar jugar jugar y experimentar nos
permite conocer qué es lo que nos rodea
el científico en cambio nos permite
respondernos el porqué de las cosas por
qué pasa esto por qué pasa lo otro
después viene el filosófico un poco más
complejo nos ayuda a entender ideas como
la religión ideas como la filosofía cómo
funciona una sociedad el artístico en
cambio con toda su armonía nos permite
dar soluciones a problemas distintos y
si en cada uno de estos etapas logramos
recoger las herramientas adecuadas llega
un día quizás ya con la cabeza blanca
como la del carlitos
llegamos al conocimiento espiritual
porque existimos y finalmente
encontramos la fe el problema
lamentablemente es que nos sentimos lo
suficiente
mucho menos menos jugamos y
experimentamos durante nuestras primeras
etapas de la vida
la última vez que el carlitos visitó el
ecuador el mes de aquiles de chile fue
en 2016 y en esta ocasión me invitó a
vivir un viaje con él el viaje que es
posiblemente el causante de que yo esté
el día de hoy parada con ustedes y el
que hizo que mi carrera universitaria
que estaba designada a ser una
científica impresionante cambiará
rotundamente en este viaje
jugamos jugamos como todos los juegos
que me había enseñado desde que era
pequeña con niños de escuela con
colegios de escuelas privadas de
escuelas particulares y era
impresionante y demasiado emocionante
ver como los más chiquititos se
emocionaban al transmitirles la
información a través del juego quién de
nosotros no se le complicó un poco
cuando estaba aprendiendo geometría pero
hay juegos que te permiten hacer eso
mucho más divertido el problema fue que
a medida que yo iba subiendo en cursos
subiendo en edad en esas aulas me iba
encontrando con cabezas apagadas la luz
de los niños que estaban en los primeros
grados se convertía en
una aula llena de cabezas vacías de
gente que simplemente estaba esperando
el momento de salida para salir y no
solo los alumnos también los profesores
y lo que más impotencia me daba es que
dentro de esas cabecitas habían personas
que querían hacerlo querían seguir
aprendiendo pero posiblemente el entorno
en el que se encontraban iba a ser que
se dejen llevar en ese entonces yo ya
estaba estudiando biología en la
universidad me comencé a apasionar y
enamorarme de subir y bajar montañas de
ver las flores pequeñitas que habían en
cada uno de estos lugares y con los
niños jugábamos experimentos durante los
recreos emilio un niño de 78 años
obviamente el más indisciplinado de su
clase siempre estaba conmigo en los
recreos y un día cuando estábamos
buscando muestras para ver debajo del
microscopio me dijo una frase que
posiblemente muchos de nosotros la hemos
dicho sencilla pero que me dejó pensando
me dijo y yo que creía que la ciencia
era aburrida
yo ya estaba enamorada de la ciencia a
través de la academia y de todo lo que
estaba estudiando ya me había enamorado
de la ciencia lastimosamente me di
cuenta de que todo ese enamoramiento
vino porque yo era parte de un selecto
grupo que tenía acceso a esa información
esa información estaba dentro de la
academia y no iba a salir de ahí y niños
como emilio posiblemente seguirán
creciendo pensando que la ciencia es la
materia aburrida que te dan en el
colegio para ponerte una nota y que
muchas veces te hacen tener miedo de
esto en ese momento junto con el
problema que vi dentro de las aulas
decidí hacer algo tenía que interponer
me entre ese cambio de los niños
chiquitos hacia los niños grandes y
sobre todo tenía que buscar un puente de
ohl para poder unir lo que me apasionaba
de la naturaleza de la biología y
también lo que me estaba pasión ando en
ese momento
y como nada en esta vida es coincidencia
y cuando las cosas tienen que pasar
pasan un día recibí un mensaje de la
calle una compañera de universidad no
había hablado demasiado con ella pero
este mensaje me estaba invitando a hacer
algo me estaba invitando a un proyecto
en el que ella quería transformar la
información que estaba dentro de
artículos académicos en cuentos cuentos
para grandes pequeños de todas las
edades y condiciones
por supuesto que quería ayudarle era de
hecho la pieza clave que estaba buscando
para unir esto que yo estaba
preguntándome dentro de mi cabeza y por
suerte no solo quería ayudarla durante
mi vida universitaria conocí a la gente
adecuada que nos iba a permitir llevar
esta idea un poco más allá fue cuestión
de unos días reunir a las esferas del
dragón a mis esferas del dragón y en una
clase de esta misma universidad hace un
año aproximadamente muchos de ellos ni
siquiera se conocían nos sentamos a
soñar nos sentamos a poner sobre la mesa
todas nuestras pasiones artísticas
dibujar pintar escribir nos sentamos a
poner también todos nuestros dones sobre
la mesa mezclarlos y crear lo que ahora
es dragón de polylepis dragón porque
envuelve la fantasía que nosotros
sentíamos cuando eran internos niños
quien no se inspiró con una historia de
harry potter o el señor de los anillos'
y paul in the peace porque él polylepis
es el único árbol que llega más arriba
en las montañas y no solo eso también es
parte de aquí de sudamérica y además le
dicen árbol de papel el papel que
nosotros queremos cumplir dentro de la
educación y el papel de que el que
posiblemente van a estar nuestros
cuentos para llegar a todos los niños y
personas que quieran escucharlos
desde ahí la cuenta simplemente comenzó
a seguir es impresionante como cuando
una cosa está destinada a ser
simplemente el camino se te abre
comenzamos a crear más personajes el
dragón de agua de fuego de roca y muchos
otros
después nos comenzamos a ver en frente
de público niños que realmente estaban
escuchando nuestros cuentos a llevarles
muestras a hacer que miren a través del
microscopio y se emocionen de la misma
manera que cualquier científico
apasionado se emociona al estudiar el
individuo que es objetivo de su estudio
después comenzamos a probar con más
grandecitos adolescentes de un público
difícil y a trabajar con diferentes
instituciones que nos permitían llevar
la ciencia hacia la gente hacia donde
tiene que estar
y nos comenzamos a topar con reacciones
como estas o quizás reacciones como
estas ojitos de enamorados que a través
de nuestros cuentos estaban viviendo la
ciencia la estaban sin tiempo una mamá
una vez nos contó que cuando su hija
estaba viajando hacia la costa de
repente hizo que pare porque la hija le
dijo mami mami en ese bosque vive el
dragón una niña que lo que había
conocido un bosque de polylepis le hizo
para su madre porque ahí vivía el dragón
pero bueno esto está muy hablado y ya
que la historia no se le cuenta de la
misma manera a todos quiero invitarles a
que ustedes también se permitan sentir
esa naturaleza les voy a pedir a todos
que cierren sus ojos por favor es
importante todos por favor cierren sus
ojos y van a dejarse llevar por lo que
escuchan
[Música]
estamos en las montañas de repente el
cielo se nubla y comienzan a caer
pequeñas gotas de agua agua y al llegar
al suelo se transforma en nieve es la
primera vez que vine
comienza a tocarles la cara y de repente
sienten que algo los está persiguiendo
nos ve dentro de las sombras comienzan a
apurar el paso la las plantas cambiaron
ahora sólo hay hierro y el rocas en ese
momento lo veis abren los ojos y lo ven
es del zorro andino imponente salvaje
pero si ustedes logran conocerlo
realmente puede ser el travieso que les
daña los proyectos de la tesis
el fiel compañero que espera mientras
ustedes terminan su trabajo especies
como ésta viven en las montañas
soportando condiciones drásticas todos
los días es impresionante cómo lo hacen
lamentablemente especies como estas
están amenazadas por lo que nosotros
hacemos diariamente él y muchos como él
están desapareciendo
si ustedes se trasladaron a un lugar
parecido a esto estamos bien ustedes se
permitieron sentir que se permitieron
sentir un poquito de esa vida y de esa
magia que siempre les está rodeando
sin darme cuenta muchos de los juegos
que yo jugaba de pequeña me ayudaron a
resolver problemas de adultos muchas de
las estrategias y mucho de esto que yo
hice me ayudaron a encontrar las pistas
del dragón a lo largo de mi camino y
aunque algunas veces quise salirme de
ese camino esta vida se encargó de que
conozca y me encuentre a las personas
adecuadas en los momentos adecuados
la ciencia la vida los sueños y la
naturaleza hay que vivirlas y si tú
quieres que un sueño crezca tienes que
trabajar duro y ser constante pero
trabajar duro y ser constante no
significa que te dejes llevar por todos
los problemas que la sociedad te impone
en ese camino tienes que ser lo
suficientemente valiente para jugar para
soñar y para dejar que ese niño que
creía en la fantasía cuando eras más
pequeño se adueñó de ti ve de vez en
cuando y a través de un corazón presto y
una mente abierta en algún punto puedes
encontrar la verdadera magia de la vida
gracias
[Aplausos]